[Music]
foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday February 21st I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
a large number of workers in the U.S
tech field are foreign and they have not
been immune from the layoffs that have
ripped through the sector for those in
the U.S on temporary skilled employment
visas known as H-1B visas the impact
goes beyond losing their jobs if an H-1B
visa holder loses their position they
have just 60 days to find a new role in
a similar field sushant Aurora is a 30
year old project manager living in
Boston he lost his job as an analyst at
a data analytics company about a month
ago it was a trauma for me at least for
a week so I was so depressed and you
know it's very hard to believe you are
not part of the company and in addition
to that you have bills to pay right you
have ready to pay now Aurora is
scrambling to figure out what to do
before he's forced to return to his home
country India but redoing his resume and
going through several rounds of
interviews can take weeks under the H-1B
visa rule rules Aurora says he's only
allowed to apply for jobs with the title
business analyst data analyst or project
manager I'm working with two to three
companies right now I told them can you
please expedite my process because I
don't have much time like if you like
take more time then I have to leave the
country I'm doing more than like 100
applications a day like try to do that
and try to enhance my skills so that I
can crack the interview and leaving
doesn't just mean throwing his stuff in
a suitcase Aurora will have to divest
his life in the states I've invested
like three to four grands in my
furniture and like this month I bought a
new car that is for sixty thousand
dollar so you know in 60 days I can't
sell my furniture in 68 days I can't you
know sell my car and pay the bank debts
you know it's very difficult to do that
if he's to leave now Aurora says he's
not sure he'll ever want to come
us definitely I won't do that because I
don't want to be the same cycle or else
if I want to live in another country
then I'll fight the immigration friendly
country
sushant Aurora is not all that unique as
the tech layoffs pile up joining me now
to discuss the bigger impact of these
job losses is Wall Street Journal
reporter de ping Chen hi to Ping thanks
for joining us thanks for having me so
start by telling us how important are
foreign workers to the tech industry
these workers are extremely important
foreign-born workers by some estimates
account for almost one quarter of all
workers in stem fields that does include
green card holders as well as
naturalized citizens but as you can see
that's an extraordinary proportion of
the town that is fueling the tech
industry right and now we're seeing
these huge layoffs
sector I mean obviously that's not all
H-1B visa holders it's not all foreign
workers but do we have a sense of how
many temporary Visa holders have been
affected there isn't any reliable way to
track these figures companies aren't
releasing them but in terms of the
number of H-1B workers affected
certainly the folks that I've spoken to
in recruiting and also lawyers who work
with affected workers have said you know
very comfortably you could say in the
tens of thousands of workers who are
being affected by these layoffs and hold
these kinds of temporary work visas
dipping we heard sushant Aurora's story
up apart from the 60-day time frame are
there other restrictions or catches that
may surprise H1B Visa holders who lose
their jobs yeah there have been some
surprise implications for folk who've
been laid off while on these visas in
some cases when traveling abroad outside
of the US that is some of them have
found not only were they laid off but
also that their work visa was no longer
valid to get back into the country and
so we're talking about people who have
lived in the U.S for many years and now
find themselves effectively locked out
of the United States and grappling with
what to do and how to get back in and
how to pack up these lives that have
suddenly been jettisoned from them
you've spoken to a number of people in
this position can you tell us a little
bit about their stories what has their
experience been like sure well in the
case of one worker we spoke to who was
laid off from Twitter in December you
know he was traveling on vacation in
Malaysia and got the notice that he was
laid out off and then realize that oh
you know how am I going to go back any
consulted with the lawyer the lawyer
advised him against trying to travel
back to the United States for fear that
doing so would set him up for all kinds
of complications down the line if he's
perceived as trying to misrepresent his
status and so since then he's just been
stuck outside of the United States which
is a place that he's lived for over a
decade now there's a chance that if he
was to get a job while abroad he could
you know transfer status and re-enter in
that way and he's trying to pursue and
think through other options and in the
meantime he just has someone a friend
watering his plants in Los Angeles and
another neighbor who's periodically
driving his car to make sure the battery
doesn't die
and his apartment is just sitting empty
well what about for people who are in
the U.S when they lose their job and
they're going through that 60-day period
what have they told you about their
experience well if you think about
trying a job hunt at this moment
especially in the tech industry which is
going through such massive layoffs it's
not a very opportune time to find a new
role that's particularly the case for
some of the workers I've spoken to who
are more in junior positions you know
maybe got hired fresh out of college
when they got hired it was a different
time in the job market there was a lot
of opportunity and at this point now
trying to look for our roles again you
know feeling a lot of stress feeling the
clock ticking and just that that sense
of desperation what am I going to do if
I can't find a job within 60 days even
in the best of times getting a job in 60
days when you think about going through
the interview rounds you know it's just
a back and forth we didn't get any sign
of response from employers it's a tough
process already you add on the 60-day
clock and the workers that we've spoken
to are just feeling under a lot of
strain and something we heard from a lot
of folk was just wishing that they had
more of a grace period because 60 days
again is really not a lot of time have
we heard anything from tech companies
about this were they trying to do
anything to help workers in this
position in some cases we know companies
have been trying to extend the date of
termination to try and give workers a
bit more of a cushion
or if you know layoffs are coming to
sort of give more of a heads up and that
way workers can start looking for jobs
earlier
but fundamentally they don't have many
obligations to workers who are on these
temporary work visas in the case of H1B
the only requirement really that they
have is to notify Federal authorities
that their employment has been
terminated and then also to help pay for
airfare home fake picture because you
know there are so many foreign temporary
workers in the tech industry what is
this going to mean for the sector going
forward people that I've spoken to in
recruiting have mentioned just the fact
that all these layoffs which of course
are hitting the industry broadly but
have a particular impact for foreign
temporary workers have noted that there
is a chilling effect right if you are
someone who is looking at your options
and you're trying to consider where do I
want to try and build a career and you
see all this upheaval and you see that
hey as a foreign worker in the U.S you
know I see a lot of these workers
getting laid off and having to abruptly
leave the country well it's one of the
people we speak of saying was you know
you might consider Canada you might
consider ultimate locations like that
Canada did recently eclipse the United
States as the most preferred Global
destination for overseas talents per
some recent surveys and there's reason
to think certainly when we're thinking
about this particular class of workers
with this certain skill set that I mean
they obviously have other options all
right that's our reporter to Ping Chen
thanks for joining us to Ping thanks for
having me and that's it for today's Tech
news briefing if you want more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas from The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
thank you